hey 42 here through science our
civilization has developed faster than
anyone could have imagined and we've
made great leaps forward in our
understanding of the universe our minds
nature and everything else but that
journey has sometimes taking us in a
pretty weird direction so today we look
at the five most bizarre scientific
experiments ever conducted the USA has
the largest prison population in the
world
we're over two million people behind
bars they prop up a lot of American
industries with prisoners making
everything from books of Braille for the
blind to lingerie to canoes all of which
sounds like rejected storylines from
Prison Break who needs a map of the
prison tattooed on your body when you've
got Braille or sexy bra in the puddle so
with all of these people locked up
we should really know a bit more about
how incarceration affects us and how it
affects the guards because as Alan Moore
asked in his award-winning comic who
watches the Watchmen this was the
purpose of the Stanford Prison
Experiment for six days in 1971
psychology professor Philip Zimbardo
paid 24 volunteers
$15 a day to play the roles of guards
and prisoners he was aiming to look at
the cause of abusive behavior was it
down to the personality of the people
involved or was it down to the system
itself the prisoners and guards were
given appropriate uniforms and prisoners
were arrested from their homes and then
put free to a cell they were given a
number and only referred to by that
number from they're not prisoners also
had a chain around one ankle to remind
them of their lack of freedom the
results were pretty shocking within just
36 hours prisoner number 86 one two had
to be removed due to going into a wild
rage all in all five prisoners had to be
removed early from the experiment and
the whole program was stopped after just
six days the plan was to go on for two
weeks some of the guards were actually
disappointed
it got stopped early they were beginning
to enjoy their rolls in fact 1/3
displayed genuine sadistic tendencies
punishments included removing mattresses
making prisoners be naked not allowing
them to empty their toilet pocket
locking them in cupboards and many more
power is a dangerous thing
even Zimbardo was forced to admit that
he had lost perspective as the
experimenter and was surprised by what
he allowed to continue post experiment
there were serious concerns about the
human rights violations carried out
during the experiment and Zimbardo even
stopped some of the prisoners from
leaving the experiment early after they
had had enough even though he told them
before it started that they could leave
at any point it was only the objections
of his girlfriend Christina Maslach that
made him finish the experiment early she
was mainly worried about the mental
health of the prisoners or maybe she was
just sick of him torturing prisoners all
day instead of helping her of the
housework our next experiment came about
as a result of a huge amount of physical
labor a goldmine dog almost 2.5
kilometres into the earth the Homestake
mine in lead South Dakota were started
in 1876 and operated for over 100 years
finally stopping production in 2001
during this time it produced over 1.25
million kilograms of gold along with
some silver as well there's still some
more gold down there now but the mine is
so deep that it's costing more money to
extract it than its sale price which is
kind of the whole point of mining as you
know scientists are basically like moles
and love doing stuff on the ground so
2007 they moved it and started looking
for something much more rarely seen than
gold
and far more valuable when it comes to
the mysteries of the universe the large
underground Zenon experiment is set
about 1.5 kilometers underground and is
designed to find evidence of dark matter
dark matter and dark energy supposedly
make up around 95
percent of our universe so only 5% are
the more tangible atoms that we deal
with on a daily basis the air we breathe
the ground beneath your feet
leftover takeaway food house you know
stuff in 1932 a physicist called Jan
Oort realized that the stars and planets
in the Milky Way were orbiting at the
wrong speed if they are the only maths
in the galaxy so he put forward the
theory that there must be something else
that we can't see that is adding a huge
amount of mass to the universe and so
the idea of dark matter was born the
problem of dark matter is that although
it's everywhere since it's far more
common than everything else in the
universe even Starbucks it's really
really weak that means we never see it
interact with any normal matter the
world we see around us is extremely
noisy there are particles bouncing
around all over the place imagine you
are holding a kid's party and you have
30 little kids all full of cakes sweets
and destructive tendencies and now
imagine and look at all this chaos
you're trying to listen out for a tiny
hamster scratching its nose you're just
never gonna hear it what's the haps
you'll probably get crushed or covered
in paint or something when you look up
into space it looks empty but actually
you are being bombarded with cosmic rays
constantly around three or four per
second so when you're looking for
something as shy as dark matter this
constant attack will make it impossible
to find you need to block out the race
and what better way to do that than by
building your lab under a mile of fifth
rock here the cosmic rays dropped from
three or four per second to just a
couple a month the scientists took a 370
kilogram box of xenon an element that is
extremely unreacted and put it into a
big tank of water scientists call it the
quietest place in the universe so what
have they found out in two years of
watching this very quiet box nothing but
are they going to give up
course not this is science they're going
to build a bigger box now if you think
two years is a long time to sit around
whilst nothing happens then you are in
for a surprise a very very slow and
boring surprise the pitch drop
experiment is designed to show that
pitch is indeed a liquid pictures are
full of petrol also known as asphalt or
bitumen and all of it looks like a solid
and you can smash it with a hammer it's
actually just an extremely viscous
liquid like the thickest blackest honey
you could imagine in 1927 at the
University of Queensland Australia
professor Thomas Parnell heated some
pitch and put it into a sealed funnel
he allowed it to settle for three years
and then cut off the tip of the funnel
so the pitch could flow out and it did
in 1938 taking just eight years it's a
good thing it fell when it did or the
whole world might have been too
distracted watching the world's most
boring experiment to get on with the war
the professor didn't get to see the drop
himself as eight years is quite a long
time to concentrate on some things so he
liked the experiment alone to do its
thing the second drop took just one more
month than the last one
but he missed it again and so on it went
and it's still going it now holds the
record as the longest continuous running
experiment of all time so what happened
when he finally saw it drop nothing
because he never did he sadly died in
2013 having missed every one of the
eight drops that the experiment had made
in 1988 he saw that it was super close
to dropping then he went to make a cup
of tea and missed it in 2000 he was away
but the wonders of modern technology
allowed him to set up a camera but guess
what the camera malfunctioned and we're
still waiting to see it ix
drop in 2014 had stretched all the way
down to the base but it was broken when
they tried to empty out the catchment
dish so it was broken artificially and
doesn't count as a drop the drops have
taken longer since they installed air
conditioning
you know to really ramp up the tension
what this really proves is that people
will keep doing something no matter how
boring or irritating just because they
can just like level 350 of candy crush
but if you want an experiment that
really shows what people are prepared to
do then the Milgram experiment is
certainly one to read up in 1961
Adolphe Eichmann one of the Nazis who
orchestrated the Holocaust was put on
trial for war crimes it was a hot topic
at the time and one of the big questions
going around was what if he was just
following orders the same as any other
soldier well Jewish psychologist Stanley
Milgram wanted to put this to the test
and he designed an experiment that has
given us great insight into the
relationship that people have with
Authority why is it for example that if
a doctor told you to take off your pants
you'd think okay but if the bus driver
told you you'd probably be calling a
hotline the Milgram experiment was
conducted at Yale University in July
1961 there were free rolls the
experimenter who was a person of
authority the teacher who was a
volunteer and the learner who the
teacher believed was another volunteer
but was actually an actor the teacher
sat in one room with a microphone and
the learner sat in another room there
was no window between the rooms the
teacher told the learner a word and then
gave a choice of four other words and
the learner had to choose to correct her
if the match was incorrect a teacher
pressed a button and gave the learner a
small electric shock at the beginning of
the experiment the teacher was given a
small test shot to demonstrate what the
learner would be experiencing but every
time the learner made a mistake the
teacher had to increase the voltage the
learner was an actor of course so there
were no real shocks but as the voltage
increased they would make louder and
louder noises and screams and complain
about their heart condition which had
been mentioned earlier on they would
bang on the walls and beg to stop if the
voltage went over a lethal dose around
300 volts they were told to make no
noise as if they had died
so how high do you think the teachers
went how many of the volunteers would
refuse to continue in their role as the
teacher when they had heard the pain of
the learner shockingly 65% of teachers
ended up giving the maximum 450 voltage
shock probably frying the corpse of
their poor dead learner
if the shocks were real of course how is
it possible do we live in a world full
of Psychopaths no it's all about the
relationship between the volunteer and
the experiment because the experimenter
is there and telling them to continue
most people feel like what they're doing
must be ok we are taught to trust people
in authority in variations of the test
they realize a lot of things make a
difference to this trust such as being
in the same room as the experimenter the
type of clothing they wear and so on
just imagine you're outside an
electronics store and there's a TV in a
box a guy walks up point at the
flat-screen TV and says that's yours
it's free go on take it you'd probably
think he was a criminal but if he was
dressed in a police uniform
boom you'd be enjoying Netflix and 70
inches quicker than you could say the
Milgram experiment our final experiment
takes us into the animal kingdom in 1962
is the swinging 60s we're just getting
going a group of scientists wondered
what happens if you give an elephant
acid
I wonder if this question actually
answers another question what happens if
you give a group of scientists acid
because this is probably how old this
madness came about in the first place
Warren Thomas who was a director of
Oklahoma Zoo took 297 milligrams of LSD
and shot it into port tusks oh the
elephant did tusks Oh begin to taste
color did he begin to like understand
the universe dude no he went on the
greatest trip of them all he died he ran
around for a couple of minutes then
keeled over and was dead in an hour
an important discovery was made don't
give us it to elephants the world is a
more enlightened place thanks to poor
Tosca actually this isn't the only case
of animals being given LSD around this
time a NASA funded project led by John
Lilly was set up to see if we could
communicate with dolphins
due to his reputation as a mind expander
they tried using acid but it didn't seem
to have any real effect interestingly
they also built a human dolphin
cohabitation space so that's a woman
called Margaret Lovett could live with
Peter the dolphin and try to teach him
English the sixties were pretty weird
weren't they that's the thing about
science though it can seem pretty crazy
until you learn something important and
then it's not so crazy after all there
is an idea that every great discovery is
an accident
since if you knew exactly what you were
looking for then you won't need to
discover it so I guess we'll just have
to let the madness continue thanks for
the view subscribe for more thoughty2